okay what's going on
it's bill burr and it's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday July
9th 2018 we'll do some dumb [ __ ] like
get her a ring then all of a sudden he's
married he's like what did I do
did he will say how you mad at me she'll
just shake her head and say no and then
she'll treat you like [ __ ] for the next
five days what's going on it never ends
people never it's um how are you what's
going on I'm out here any wave I'm still
getting over this [ __ ] a bola that I
caught I don't know what I have you know
that's just lingering I'm just I'm all
congested you know don't take it I'll
put it over your head and then [ __ ]
behind your car you have somebody
started up all right you know make sure
you have a lemon in your mouth you know
that's what it might what my [ __ ] day
is been like for the last eight days
everybody has the it's [ __ ] hilarious
all these people who aren't fun right
all of these people who've never
invented anything in their life and I
mean even just some dumb [ __ ] like you
you take some wire and you [ __ ] twist
and then you bend it and it's like look
for 1995 it's your very own back picture
right back massager yeah they've all
been telling me how to [ __ ] sure this
[ __ ] and it's just like okay alright
well I'll try that know what you say
sink the man over there in the plaid
shirt says sink what do you what say you
vitamin D you say vitamin D fine yeah I
feel like I'm on a game show
right when you're on The Price is Right
and everybody's yelling out a price like
a different number and the person's
looking with their
deer-in-the-headlights that's what it's
like when you have a [ __ ] cold by the
way me and Mike laugh who isn't
to me who isn't not not talking to me
but isn't actually really chatty either
you know do you know you get him out of
that mood you have you can't say it out
loud you can't say I don't you know I
don't even give a [ __ ] anymore at this
point I've gone through enough hours of
torture here what you do is you just
think you know what I don't give a [ __ ]
and they are so smart they sense the
second you do that and then immediately
they want to sit down and talk about it
because once you don't give a [ __ ] the
game's over okay and they don't want you
to settle into not giving a [ __ ] because
then you won't be able to listen to
their lecture and nod and go okay yes I
will work on that okay I you know what I
didn't know that oh oh do I do that is
that what I do
Wow it's it's so great to have somebody
outside myself to let me know what it is
that I'm doing you don't you like a move
like just going around my [ __ ] the
planet of my head observing not a moon
honey way maybe be like a an alien
aircraft you know of higher intelligence
does that make you feel better anyway so
it was ungodly [ __ ] hot ungodly [ __ ]
it was the hottest it's ever been was
like Palm Desert out here it was a
hundred and nine [ __ ] degrees on
Friday and I'm not I'm not even talking
about in the valley maybe that was the
valley I don't know what it was but it
was like you were war it was like I felt
like I was standing inside a dryer and
I've used that reference a lot but this
time was like oh yeah I could dry my
clothes in this you know by the way
those idiots who like well you can
[ __ ] fry an egg on the sidewalk you
could probably do that when it's like 80
degrees up you know what I mean it'd be
like frying it on low I don't know what
it would be like me you know but like on
Friday when I was 109 degrees out and
around 2:00 in the afternoon like your
[ __ ] would be over medium before you
even flicked it then you wouldn't have
to season it because of all the rock
salt right for those of you back east
and so the inevitable happens is there's
then after human beings in their own way
have made it I don't know how many
degrees hotter but we have made it
hotter I think even scientists that wear
red coats are red ties even they have
been like you know we're kind of having
an effect on the the environment
I mean if gypsy moth caterpillars have
to be stopped you know I mean what about
human beings they say what you want
about gypsy moth caterpillars you know
they they don't make you know
nuclear waste they they've never you
know invested in plastics you know
they're pretty green for what it is that
they do right and they are part of
nature so they probably really don't
need to be stopped by an outside force
like us we're stopping them for our own
[ __ ] survival and the problem is his
mother nature up until this point has
been bringing a knife to a gunfight with
like [ __ ] gypsy moth caterpillars
it's a [ __ ] like that and I think
now she's realizing that she needs to go
down to the local [ __ ] what do you
call the place she go down to the place
where there's always like a bad keyboard
and the [ __ ] window pawnshop he could
go down the pawnshop she's gonna get
herself a [ __ ] heat and heat her a
boner boner a burner whatever the [ __ ]
you call him I don't [ __ ] a boner
she's gonna come out with a [ __ ] dick
man she's gonna she's gonna do a reverse
Bruce she's gonna [ __ ] all of us in the
ass with the weather I think that that's
what I was trying to say I have no idea
but all I know was you know it was
[ __ ] insane so the inevitable happens
is then there's a power search there was
like nobody on the roads like that's how
[ __ ] ought it was everybody was just
staying inside sitting in
air-conditioning like oh my god and that
[ __ ] guy out there and then we all
after making it hotter you know I'm not
saying it wouldn't be 104 degrees or
whatever I don't even know if we made it
five degrees hot or whatever but we sit
inside and we don't get to feel we don't
feel the effects of
the [ __ ] we're doing it's like buying a
shirt you know what I mean you don't see
the [ __ ] eight-year-old that's sewed
it together you're like God did she
sharp make me look good right it's like
it's painless so now we're all sitting
there in the AC and inevitably we don't
have enough power so now they have to
have a blackout now where are they gonna
do it okay now I already gave it away
okay the key word here is blackout black
would be the key word you know I don't
know where they did it but I know they
didn't [ __ ] go well we have to shut
down the grid somewhere where should we
shut it down should we shut it down in
Beverly Hills her or [ __ ] bel-air or
these people with their [ __ ] infinity
pools that fall off into the goddamn
ocean with their panoramic views you can
literally see the roundness of the
planet you know these people with their
MTV Cribs stock [ __ ] refrigerators
the giant cabin footprint or oh now now
those people fund our campaigns let's
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] go down into these
people who can barely rub two [ __ ]
nickels together we'll shut down this
[ __ ] it's just an evil [ __ ] world map
and and oddly enough this weekend as I
sat in my air-conditioned house you know
not in Beverly Hills but not in the hood
either you know what I mean like if I
was on a chess board I wouldn't be a
pawn but I wouldn't be in the castle
either you know I don't think I'd be the
horse it wouldn't be a bishop I think
I'd be a rook you know basic forward
sideways
you know white guy no lateral [ __ ]
movement I would dag diagonal I'd
[ __ ] trip over myself or try to run a
[ __ ] in or an outright route like a
[ __ ] horse I just don't think I'd
make it you know horse the [ __ ] broad
can do whatever she wants right got all
the goddamn power at the [ __ ] a king
dude just sitting there backing up whoa
whoa hey guys surround me she's pissed
she's pissed
well she said she's not pissed but she's
not talking to me
she is but you know what I mean it's
really quick and serviceable
conversation would you like some dinner
okay it's ready
salmon nice talking to you
nothing anyways they should have like
this is such a hacky idea but they
should literally I wish they had right
now if they had like a [ __ ] like a
relationship
tell me Ari something must have done a
bit like this like you have like a
relationship meteorologist you know what
I mean that could give you a five-day
[ __ ] forecast let you know what kind
of coat to wear basically what kind of
what kind of [ __ ] am I gonna try to
avoid so I don't step into it you know
what I mean so anyways I'm in the
[ __ ] house right and you know I got
the kid now and she's getting bigger and
eventually she's gonna need a road room
alright and I have all and I don't even
have a lot of [ __ ] but I have all I have
a lot of [ __ ] I didn't think I had a lot
of [ __ ] I don't have a lot of furniture
but I have a lot of [ __ ] you know just
over the years going on the road buying
a little thing here buy a little thing
there fan giving you something the venue
giving you something and all of a sudden
you just got a bunch of [ __ ] and then
what happens is if enough time goes by
used to I don't know I'm sentimental I
start to develop feelings for it and
it's hard to get rid of it well I don't
have a choice now people so in the near
future I'm gonna I am going to have a
massive massive [ __ ] giveaway of
memorabilia and [ __ ] and and old drum
stuff and like you know I tried to give
some people might my old drum magazines
and just nobody wanted them all these
[ __ ] young kids are like you know I
stick
phone bro you know I just go to the
[ __ ] I can read this on my phone like
like I'm I don't know what like I you
think I was handed I'm like a hammer and
a chisel in a rock and be like you wanna
drop pictures with this so I didn't feel
too bad because they're made out of
paper although I'm sure the ink is bad
for the environment but I I put like 20
years of all of these [ __ ] magazines
that I saved like I was gonna go back
and peruse through two decades of
[ __ ] drum magazines and I kept some
of them you know the Jon Theodore is the
[ __ ] Nicko McBrain the [ __ ] Steve
Jordan you know all the way back all the
drummers sent a [ __ ] love right Tommy
Lee you know but then you know the
latest ones were the easiest ones to get
rid of because I'm an old man and I
probably didn't know a lot of those
players although I probably should but
[Music]
you know I don't know I just wish I
could go back in time and not buy
anything you know Jimmy the gent don't
what the [ __ ] that I say don't buy
anything you know as much as he was a
murderous psychopath he was very
environmentally conscious in that part
of Goodfellas you know so anyways just
giving you guys a heads up I I got it
all out in front of me here I got it all
laid out and my wife who's not mad at me
is you know she was like well why don't
you get like a storage shed you know you
like this stuff and it's like I'm not
[ __ ] doing that I'm not doing that
like whenever I see those places I get
like I have a [ __ ] almost a physical
reaction to them when I see a storage
facility and it's just like I'm not I
did that before I'm not [ __ ] doing
that then you have to go back and like
check in on your stuff it's like your
stuff went to jail and then you know you
can just [ __ ]
they hang on a second I got a [ __ ]
Texas goodnight back
there's no way free to continue talking
call you in in a 45 minute anyways it's
just then you do in the George Carlin
but you just have [ __ ] just spread out
all over the [ __ ] world and it's just
like if there's not like Fox shut up
alright if there's not room enough for
it in your house like we have more rooms
that could be bedrooms than people here
okay it's just me while my wife or my
daughter so there's no [ __ ] reason
why there should be no room other than
the fact that we just have too much [ __ ]
and I'm not throwing it out I threw out
the magazine's cuz they're made out of
paper and I don't really give a [ __ ]
about the ink but I'm really trying to
[ __ ] think about where this stuff is
gonna end up okay and I don't know so
I'm gonna try it like you know I figure
if I could just get some of this [ __ ] if
you guys want it you know I'll just
[ __ ] give the stuff away or whatever
I hope some people aren't going to get
mad cuz some of the stuff is like [ __ ]
that venues have given me you know some
sports jerseys with my name on the back
of them and stuff which is [ __ ] cool
or whatever but like you know I'm not
gonna lie never wore it and I always
appreciated the gesture but I just took
it and I put it in a box and then I just
started piling these [ __ ] things up
and I I don't have any more [ __ ] room
I don't know what to do with them so my
new [ __ ] thing from here on out 50
[ __ ] years old is Jimmy the gent
I'm not [ __ ] buying anything I'm not
buying anything you know and I'm trying
to get my wife on the same [ __ ] page
but you know you know that's not working
you know what I mean
Jesus Christ
tellin her not to go on Amazon is like
her telling me not to get shit-faced on
a Tuesday I mean it's just not happening
by the way speaking of drinking I have a
drink you would know it from my voice I
sound like [ __ ] but I haven't drank
since the end of June and that's all
it's so [ __ ] up it's so [ __ ] up
about it it's just like food I think the
same relationship with food that I have
with booze that I do is I just [ __ ]
walk away for a few days it what the
[ __ ] am i doing and what I say food
walking away it's like sugar and [ __ ]
and bad food and I start eating well and
then all of a sudden if I look at bad
feels like I'm gonna [ __ ] eat that
I'm gonna feel that way okay the same
thing with booze like you know when I'm
drinking and I see a bottle of booze I
swear to god it's like you know it's
backlit at the bar I mean it just looks
like you drink in life
it just looks golden you know so
inviting and then when I just stopped
drinking I just looked at in like Jesus
I don't wanna [ __ ] it I don't mess with
that [ __ ] okay what the [ __ ] that I
dunno
now what I gotta apologize for I know
I'm wrong that's the worst thing about
it you know what I mean Jesus does it
ever [ __ ] end you know what I mean
ice this is like when I was a kid my
mother was mad at me and I didn't she
wouldn't tell me I gotta [ __ ] figure
out what I did I love it all these
[ __ ] TV shows where they sit there
and they always sit there and they talk
about how weight living toss ate twice
as many [ __ ] words in a day and how
that great at communicating it's like no
they're not they're not they're not good
at communicating they speak in favor
[ __ ] riddles can he tell she told
Mike he whispered so you speak in
[ __ ] riddles
I'm sorry nobody mind today younger
right now sitting at Ellen of going like
- but you gotta understand about a woman
is by the time they ate they got the
whole [ __ ] thing planned out not all
of them but enough of them and you're
still sitting there playing in a [ __ ]
mud puddle or jumping off a jungle gym
going hey mom look what the [ __ ] I could
do whatever kids do nowadays you know
[ __ ] dancing with your [ __ ] toy
robot whatever you guys do they got it
all planned out that's why how many
times guys have you been out on a date
with a woman and she said some [ __ ] to
you that sounded like a riddle and
you're like what the [ __ ] and then he
answered the question and then she goes
like no you're supposed to say blah blah
blah blah blah blee bloo like it I
didn't know there was a script nobody
sent me the sides for my part like they
have the whole [ __ ] thing the whole
[ __ ] thing mapped out and you
basically you have three options
you really just accept it or die alone
or you go out buy a wife-beater and you
become that guy you don't want to do
that if he blaming women for some ethics
violence shut up oh god I'm just [ __ ]
around you know I was on Twitter right
and somebody wrote some [ __ ]
hilarious smartass thing about me so I
clicked on their profile because I was
just like you know what that is above
average [ __ ] talk is this another comic
is this is an up-and-coming comic I
don't know it was like almost a comedian
level funny so I went to this person's
threat and I you know read their little
blurb couldn't figure what they did so I
scrolled down to try to figure out are
they a comedian look for a stay in a
picture and one of the things this
person had retweeted was from this
something something feminist it was
talking about Donald Trump and and was
saying like Donald Trump just made fun
of the victims of me - in the crowd
roared with approval period and then
again she wrote roared with approval
right and then she had the link of my
god oh my god he's kidding this is what
he did today this guy's [ __ ] crazy
so I clicked on it and he made a
roundabout reference to me too
you know he was using me to the way some
people use Millennials which is not
right I'm not saying it's right to do
that
you know I'm not trying to be a [ __ ]
here but I am a comedian and I've been
on stage for 26 years
they did not roar with approval okay he
got a chuckle
he got a polite chuckle I'm not saying
they weren't meatheads a I'm not saying
hey he said was backing right but the
crowd did not roar with approval period
roared with approval and it just as a
comedian that [ __ ] annoyed me cuz
ever back in the day you'd see these
[ __ ] comics get offstage ah dude I
crushed I [ __ ] crushed NBC he [ __ ]
he got the job done
that's not killing you can't stop
walking around saying you killed it
didn't Donald Trump didn't kill okay if
that was his [ __ ] audition set for a
club and those were the laughs he was
getting they would say you know what
he's not ready yet but I'd say he's not
funny he sees he was getting some laughs
but he was alright buddy I don't think
he's ready for a weekend spot yet like
he was getting like two Monday Tuesday
level laughs like back you know when
there was some sort of [ __ ] system in
the clubs when they would actually build
talent they used to have you know Monday
was like an open mic night at Nick's and
then the big deal was your next move and
Nick's economy stopping Boston the next
move was the host Billy Martin who's now
like you know one of the main men over
there at Bill Maher show he then had a
show Wednesday night at the kowloon and
that was the first big [ __ ] move out
of the open mics I got a spot at the
kowloon and you'd say that to the other
open mic cars and they just burned
through the crowd of open mic is dude he
Parker died spot at the kowloon and then
I remember thinking like the first time
I did a spot at the kowloon I was so
[ __ ] nervous because this was the
first time I went on in front of a crowd
that was not expecting to see an open
mic er they did not go to an open mic
show going alright let's see what these
[ __ ] people have or I'm here to see a
friend of mine like they came out to see
a comedy show and they were like I
gonna give you we're gonna hand you the
keys for five minutes let's see what the
[ __ ] you do right so I would say I would
say that that's where Trump was in that
speech he was doing five minutes at the
kowloon all right this has nothing to do
about what the [ __ ] he said or whatever
but I did find it interesting though but
that's how she heard it she heard them
roaring with laughter yeah like and when
you [ __ ] listen to Trump go and fake
news fake news like it necessarily
sometimes it's fake but it's more just
people hear [ __ ] and then whatever
they're passionate with it just it
raises the [ __ ] levels you know like
you know with me this you know you know
you guys at this point if you listen
long enough you know the [ __ ] that sets
me off
alright and like the amount of [ __ ]
times I lose my [ __ ] and I think it's
going it's going a certain way and then
I find out not only am I not right I am
a hundred percent it's a complete 180
it's going the other direction now I'm
not saying that this woman should have
not have been upset you know and also
been upset that people chuckled you know
but they did not roar with laughter I'm
just being a kunti comedian right now
you know there's just certain things
that people say that that goes into the
terminology the terminology of a
comedian and it bugs me like the thing
that I you know I talked about about a
year ago or two years ago was this
[ __ ] phenomenon where all of a sudden
people started saying the I love when
the comedian heckled the crowd it's like
no no the community doesn't heckle the
crowd the comedian gets heckled a
heckler goes to a performance and tries
to disrupt a performance of speech
anything that is a heckler all right for
a comedian to be heckling a crowd the
crowd to be got to be collectively
giving some sort of [ __ ] performance
that he's interrupting all right you
could say the comedian snapped I love
when you [ __ ] just lost your [ __ ] on
that guy but I'm not heckling the crowd
like oh look at how you sit in your
seats you call that a show sorry
whatever so anyways how many have you
[ __ ] Mincy that's 24 minutes got damn
that ain't bad Danny baby any better at
all hey let's talk about World Cup
soccer huh what's what's you know I
usually wait to talk about NFL football
I know the theme song I don't know what
the the World Cup thing is you know but
I've watched enough of it that I know in
the end they're gonna go to the wrap-up
with the fashionable lady then there's
the old like guy looks he's like you
know fell off a stool at a pub he's
probably some old [ __ ] football
player you know and then there's the
excitable like sort of fat guy who looks
like with the mustache you know am I
allowed to say Latino was a white guy I
mean he is a light Latino dude he looks
like the guy that one of the first guys
that gets killed in a [ __ ] mob movie
and then the other ones it seemed like
they just had a revolving chair like I
recognize this black dude with dreads as
being like wasn't he on our [ __ ] team
the USA team oh by the way I finally
figured out how to [ __ ] tell who the
[ __ ] is who in a World Cup game if you
didn't get there at the beginning this
is how it works in American TV on Fox
Sports they basically right next to the
the team name they'll have the smallest
little sliver of color and that's the
color of the uniform like I watched
Russia first Croatia and I'm just
sitting there literally waiting for
somebody to [ __ ] score so I could
figure out who the [ __ ] is who I'm
sitting there of course you know for
[ __ ] I don't know two three hours I'm
kidding man it was a it was a [ __ ]
unbelievable game but I finally
understood out no I somebody explain it
to me on Twitter
start tweeting about going you know III
don't know who the [ __ ] is who here you
know and uh and I had this weird thing
like I didn't know who to root for
because there was something so [ __ ]
funny to me if the Russians won the
World Cup and I would just would have
been so awesome listening to people
losing their [ __ ] over here and getting
all wound up again saying that they you
know tampered with the election over
here you know and then everybody just
starts yelling at each other again it's
just I was looking forward to that
you know just adding to the [ __ ] heat
up here but anyways it was an incredible
game and I cannot [ __ ] balloon for
Croatia you know although every time
they cut to the Russians in the crowd I
was just like you know those are some
good-looking people you know there's
really no middle ground with Russian
stuff you know what I mean ordered
Eastern Europeans they're either late
look like [ __ ] supermodels or they
look like it's still like medieval times
you know what I mean
I mean they got some women over there
that looked like they could easily
[ __ ] impress some NFL scouts you know
in the in the we know the NFL Combine
when they they're pushing up to 25 how
many reps they can do I'm not you know
of course they wouldn't get drafted
after the 40 but I'm just saying they
you know but then they got some other
ones it's like oh my god gorgeous I'm
[ __ ] with you I'm not saying that you
know there's not alone if we don't look
at Americans but that was the one one of
the really cool things looking at that
thinking of all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that goes on at a political level you
know with the missiles and all of that
[ __ ] and then just to watch all these
Russians losing their [ __ ] minds
every time Russia would score a goal so
long story short that's thinking with
the Croatian crowd same thing [ __ ]
really good-looking people man did I
mention that I'm gonna be doing an
Eastern European tour the beginning of
next year you know and I will be
bringing all of your [ __ ]
good-looking numbers down a half a
degree during the time in your [ __ ]
country
please come up to me in your native
tongue and tell me that you can fix my
bald problem balding problem saint
balding I'm bald and that you can you
know I can fix that I am the greatest in
Transylvania that's why I approach
people in the street with my [ __ ]
business card I'm sweaty yes I'm
watching this [ __ ] game and like I'm
doing the typical American thing like oh
okay these people you just look at this
level would [ __ ] me every secret songs
to you doing that [ __ ] and all of a
sudden Croatia scores a goal and I just
I don't I couldn't control myself I was
just like you [ __ ] lost my [ __ ] right
and then Russia comes back immediately I
thought believe I watched so many games
I forget they [ __ ] scored and [ __ ]
the Russian fans are going nuts and I'm
like all these [ __ ] I bet you
know you know me I'm most conspiracy
they flatter me Lattimer and Putin you
know he's got he's got the [ __ ] he's
got the he's got the invisible hand you
know and then Croatia scores and it's
[ __ ] two-to-one there's like barely
any time left and I just I almost made
my daughter jump out of the chair in the
other room I yelled so loud when they
scored and I was like holy [ __ ] this is
gonna be unbelieving that [ __ ] guy
number ten number ten is a beast of
Croatia right and there's like no time
left and all of a sudden Russia gets
like a [ __ ] corner kick and I was
just sitting there I had my hands over
my mouth just going like oh no come on
and then he [ __ ] kicks it this
beautiful whatever the [ __ ] you call it
you know it was like a pass into the
slot they don't in a hockey like a
saucer pass just right over everybody's
[ __ ] head and it just goes right to
this one Russian dude who just makes it
glances it off his head into the back of
the net and I just go and every time I
yelled I've surprised myself a guy can't
believe how [ __ ] into this game I am
so my laughs it might and my daughter
are getting ready to leave and I'm like
you I'm sorry I we can't leave I have to
see the end of this game she
like is there is like is this is yet
another thing that your [ __ ] into I'm
like yeah I go it's the shootout
whatever they're the penalty whatever
the [ __ ] they call it and i sat there
like literally like I was like that
tarkanian guy like chewing on a [ __ ]
towel I was in the kitchen you know cuz
I had to keep you know leave in the
[ __ ] room and I had like the [ __ ]
towel you dry dishes with so my wife is
going you're gonna throw that in the
hamper I'm like alright I'm [ __ ] on on
the thing and just the level the level
of [ __ ] pressure and if you miss one
of those penalty kicks and your team
only loses by one like you just get [ __ ]
for the rest of your life you know I
mean there was that guy in Columbia I
think I don't know if he got killed
because of that but I'm he was pretty
[ __ ] suspicious I was incredible game
and like it's safe to say that I 100%
get it and I actually love the game now
there I said it
I love soccer it's a [ __ ] great game
I finally get it I [ __ ] get it you
know and then how great the World Cup is
where it's truly is a world championship
and then what's great is if you lose
okay that other team is can talk [ __ ] to
you for the next three [ __ ] years and
because it's once every four years but
you're not even guaranteed that you're
gonna get in so when you get to back the
[ __ ] close when you lose now I get it
now I get what I'm sitting there
watching grown men crying who are in
their 50s and 60s cuz they're sitting
there going like it's not gonna happen
in my lifetime I'm gonna die without
ever seeing them holding up an
astoundingly small trophy for a true
world championship do you see how big
the [ __ ] Stanley Cup is that's 30
teams 31 whatever the [ __ ] they're up to
is that the whole world
you got why the [ __ ] is the trophy so
small
it's so funny when they win it and they
all try to run around with it they're
all like you know trying to hold it up
they're like bumping heads and [ __ ] like
they keep the king they should make it
bigger but you know what that's classic
[ __ ] that's how American thinks
that's how we think you know bigger is
better it is and you know something as
much as you guys sit there and you [ __ ]
on us in the back of your heads you're
jealous of it yeah you jealous how fat
we get you jealous how big they make the
jeans over here and you jealousy you
could actually be that fat and still get
down the [ __ ] Street because you guys
are over there driving around and your
[ __ ] cow path you know past all your
ruins and your [ __ ] castles and all
that [ __ ] why am I in such a mood right
now all right I got to turn the light on
the [ __ ] Sun went down was I'm
talking here hang on he's got the whole
world it is heads that's gonna be one of
the first songs you teach a kid right
kind of it's religious it's easy all
right let's look at some of the
advertising here for this week's show so
congratulations to uh Croatia I mean
know Jesus and then there were four
England versa
tomorrow France vs. Belgium I'm sorry on
Tuesday well I guess that will be
tomorrow Matt I'm Eunice France first
Belgium on Wednesday
I'm working both day so I'm at the tape
the games and hopefully you know
somebody on the [ __ ] set will say
something god damn it that would he get
the [ __ ] you gonna do anyways let's read
some of the some of the [ __ ]
advertising here is it so weird that I I
hate reading out loud so much that I I
get upset what I have a lot of
advertising it's actually money I know
but I have to read Dollar Shave Club
everybody Dollar Shave Club delivers
everything ya need to look feel smell
smell your best Dollar Shave Club
everything you need to get ready in the
bathroom and delivers everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
did they just write that twice I might
like [ __ ] having a stroke right now
your you name it you may be that lady I
got ping screens big day yeah they
should ever read this [ __ ]
shampoo conditioner body wash toothpaste
hair gel even a wipe that Olevia tush
feeling tingly clean you know out of all
the complimentary gifts I would have
loved to have gotten that one all of
Dollar Shave club's products are made
with top-shelf ingredients that won't
break your budget
you feel the difference plus shipping is
included with all your membership it is
a great way to touch to touch to try a
bunch so yeah that's how I do it I
combined try and punch and some I got
touch I just saw the CH of Dollar Shave
club's products slow down bill for just
five bucks you can get their daily
essentials started Cosette daily
essentials start is dead
damn what do you smell so scintillating
because of my daily essential starter
set it comes with body cleanser one wipe
Chari they're amazing but wipes
that's so funny but but it's such like a
not attractive worry so like blunt what
but you can't say amazing ass wipes
because people get called you [ __ ]
ass wipe I'm an amazing ass wipe you
know rectum wipes you know daddy yeah
they're world-famous shave that's what
the French of this [ __ ] let me come over
that's an ass daddy yeah and their best
razor this six blade executive do you
realize if England and France play each
other in the World Cup final we'll
probably start another [ __ ] war over
there in Europe you know someone will
bring up Napoleon or some King George
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] those people does
always what the powdered wakes with them
and added shampoo toothpaste or anything
else you need for the bathroom check it
all out a jolly shape club
I'm / / that's Jalla Shave Club com / /
all right that's one frame bridge
everybody I got four reeds here in honor
of the four people left in the World Cup
all right that first one went out to
France all right this one goes out to
[ __ ] and who there play at Belgium frame
bridge if you've been listening to this
show you've heard me talk about frame
bridge they make it super easy and
affordable to frame your favorite things
from add prints and posters to the
travel photos sitting on your phone
here's how it works just go to frame
bridge comm and upload your photo or
they'll send you a package to safely
mail in your physical pieces gross
[ __ ] Syracuse preview your item online
in any frame style choose your favorite
or get free recommendations from their
talented designers that's for me like I
can't pick it out the black frame there
the expert team at frame bridge will
custom frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang I just [ __ ] have an
unbelievable amount of empathy for
someone who's gonna sit there on the
phone with some dope like me he goes I
want dish picture frame but I don't know
what color well let's take a look at it
well your pants are white the [ __ ] stain
is brown I don't know I'm thinking
orange instead of the hundreds you pay
at framings and a framing store their
prices start at $39 in all shipping is
free
plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order at frame bridge comm when
they use my code bar
recommended editorial I think give your
personal experience using frame bridge
I'm doing it right now
I haven't got it back yet alright but I
got this very romantic beautiful picture
of me and my wife in front of our
favorite cafe in Paris alright and then
we have other ones with our little
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] boo bear front
of the Eiffel Tower and the [ __ ] op
de Triomphe you know my parents came to
London I got some pictures to do with
them when they're the Tower Bridge I'm
getting all of that stuff done I can't
wait to see what they do all right
okay whose kid knew I just outed myself
because you would like bull then bill
why I thought you said you didn't pick
out the frames did you talk to somebody
over there no I had Andrew do all of
this all right I can comment on the
finished product call to action
must-read get started today frame your
photos or send the perfect gift for
weddings birthdays and special events go
to frame bridge calm and use the promo
code bar you'll save an additional 50%
off your first order just go to frame
bridge comm Provo Cooper robocco / all
right this next one's for Croatia when I
say CRO you say Asia expressvpn with all
the recent news about data hacks and
breaches it's hard not to worry about
digital privacy what happened recently
was there a big one I didn't hear about
it then again you know I watch me TV my
new show 7 77 Sunset Strip no matter
what you do online your mobile cares
that volcano still erupting your mobile
carrier and Internet service provider
track it all every website you visit
every email you send it's ridiculous so
take back your privacy by using Express
VPN Express VPN is the world's leading
's greatest VPN provider that lets you
securely use your internet without being
tracked by anyone not even the North
Koreans expressvpn keeps online activity
private and anonymous while you browse
email download or stream expressvpn is
great for streaming content you can even
use it to watch the world cup without a
cable subscription how cool is that
they're easy to use app encrypts all
Internet data and hides the IP address
protecting the entire connection
expressvpn cost less than seven bucks a
month and run seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone or
tablet every time you use the internet
without expressvpn you're putting
sensitive data in
risk call the action take back your
internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three free months go to
expressvpn comm / / that's exp ress
expressvpn comm know I supposed to exp
re SS VPN comm / bar for 3 months with a
one-year package visit Express VPN calm
/ bar to learn more and lastly but not
leastly for Englund
stamps.com create your own stamps calm
account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done it's convenient it's easy it's
reliable its efficient it's like that
wonderful [ __ ] and easy check up the
street
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the United States Postal
Service right to your fingertips tips
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer stamps.com makes
it easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates extra postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs now needs at least an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments IU stamps comm whenever I
send out my posters which I am sending
out on this tour I am a [ __ ] if I can
figure out if I can figure out how to do
it so can you and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps calm service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage in a digital scale go
to stamps calm click on the microphone
stop the whole page and type in BER that
stamps comm enter BER Oh righty then
alright hang on a second hang on a
second all right let's get on well we
can't get on to the letters I have to
talk about the f1 race that was in Great
Britain back to back
I'd have to say these are the two most
exciting races I've seen since I've been
watching which has been Monaco 2016 I've
seen almost every race since then what a
[ __ ] race Lewis Hamilton was trying to
he got
pole position for like the eighth
[ __ ] time in a row there I think he's
one like the last six or seven he always
dominates there he had a rough showing
didn't even finish and it did not finish
this last one whatever the [ __ ] they
were and remember in Austria and you
knew Mercedes was going to come back
strong so the race starts all right
I believe Lewis Hamilton was in first
Vettel was in second Kimi räikkönen was
somewhere in there and only they go into
the first [ __ ] turn Lewis Hamilton
something you hardly ever see has a bad
start fennel blows by him Hamilton gets
his [ __ ] car going I don't understand
did he pop the clutch I don't get how
they have a bad start I don't understand
that Atari [ __ ] steering wheel that
they're doing there I know I don't get
it
there is no clutch anymore I don't you
know what they've got a little paddle
thing there I have no [ __ ] idea but
sometimes they don't hit the right
button and they just go in too slow I
don't know but they blame the driver
right so anyway so they get into the
first [ __ ] turn and all of a sudden
valtteri botas comes screaming in out of
nowhere Vettel's in first place Lewis
Hamilton's all of a sudden in third I
was like no [ __ ] way and then out of
nowhere you just see all this smoke and
[ __ ] and the announcers are going nuts
and Lewis Hamilton got hit by Kimi
räikkönen and any [ __ ] spun out and
he went from in like one turn or two
turns from being first in the race to
being last and it was just like what the
[ __ ]
and then I believe at that point it was
Vettel botas and then Kimi räikkönen oh
maybe max Verstappen went up there but
you know the Red Bull T team was right
there by the way the United States the
[ __ ] hasti we were we've qualified
fifth and six we were killing it until
we [ __ ] slammed into each other like
[ __ ] and I took our selves out of
the points I am we maybe got one point I
don't think we came in 10th man [ __ ]
sucked but we're doing better man we are
doing better and I think that's the team
that I want really want to win and if
anybody has
to do with American Racing but we're
we're having a great season if we could
just quit [ __ ] up
and for whatever plowing ahead so Lewis
Hamilton is not out of the race he gets
his car going again and which is one of
my favorite things when a great driver
like him a Sebastian Vettel gets knocked
all the way the back of the race then
you get to watch him go through the
field and he was driving all my cars
messed up it's messed up the rear end
they go now you're fine you're fine
you're fine
and he just tears through the whole
field basically up until the top five
and then they even when he got top five
he was still like 25 seconds behind
that's how superior basically Red Bull
well really Mercedes Ferrari is and then
Red Bull and so Mercedes adopted this
we're just gonna stop once like I don't
know if you're not into this [ __ ] it's
actually like fascinating like pinning
and all of that stuff is you can win and
lose it and long story [ __ ] short is
by the end of the race for like the
final five laps because Mercedes only
pitted one time and Ferraris pitted at
least twice because I think one time
they went in like I never understand how
it works with like to put the with the
safety car out there or whatever the
[ __ ] they call it pace car or some [ __ ]
right but anyways all of a sudden five
laps left it's felt terrible toss is in
first place
Sebastian phenols right behind him with
fresher tires what's-his-face
Lewis Hamilton driving like a maniac
once again with not as fresh tires
because they only stopped at once so
they're all [ __ ] chewed up and
they're right on his ass is that [ __ ]
psycho Kimi räikkönen who I [ __ ] love
drives like a maniac got a 10-second
penalty by the way because they said he
smashed into Lewis Hamilton he didn't
need to do that and he was yelling at
his [ __ ] pit crew and all that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] great so they're all driving
like absolute [ __ ] maniacs and once
again I'm screaming at the TV yeah once
again at a sport I never thought I would
be into
and unfortunately for Vettel I
cuz his tires just crapped out and he
just didn't have enough grip and I'm
sorry I felt terrible toss I'm sorry his
tires just crapped out and Vettel was
able to duck underneath him and then he
then he gave Wade the Lewis Hamilton
which I thought was really cool and then
Hamilton was trying to stay on his ass
and they just didn't have the [ __ ]
tires and watch his face botas headed up
I think he went all the way down in like
fifth or six but the final was Sebastian
Vettel for Ferrari Lewis Hamilton for
Mercedes and then Kimi räikkönen on the
podium there was two Ferraris in a
Mercedes Sebastian Vettel's down 8
points up and the Ferrari team I think
is like 20 points up for the year and
they got two more races before the
summer break they couldn't be any closer
it's gonna be [ __ ] great [ __ ] anyways
Jesus Christ by the way just hit pause
that coughing fit went on for like
another nine two [ __ ] seconds let's
read some advertising here so anyways
the next one I believe is I think it's
in Germany or is it the Hungarian a
little next to but I got to think a
MotoGP is coming up I hope I didn't
[ __ ] like my stupid uh
recorder isn't [ __ ] not is it
recording those things because sometimes
it gets bumped down in priority I don't
know the [ __ ] that works alright okay in
regard to Eastern European Tour dear
bill you mentioned planning East
European Tour I just want to make two
just wanted to mention to think about
visiting one of former Yugoslavian
countries in the Balkans if this plan
moves forward I emailed you from
Belgrade Serbia but anything here like
Croatia Bosnia or even Slovenia can work
for local fans check out some stats
where you have the most site visits or
something as it would be interesting to
see you live somewhere near stand-up is
still relatively rising here but I am
sure it might be interesting for you to
visit if you are around here
dude I will go there and [ __ ] eat my
balls in a second
what am I ever gonna go there I'll be
close enough that you can jump on a
train write your papers please however
the [ __ ] it works over there you know
Eastern Europe scares me but that's
still behind the communist bloc like for
most of my life so then I know you know
once Russia went out of there you guys
kind of picked up some hatfield-mccoy
[ __ ] that you hadn't finished you know
I've got a little crazy there with the
[ __ ] genocide stop you know get a
little nuts over there so uh you know
you guys don't [ __ ] around over there's
what I'm trying to say it's not like
you're going to Canada oh hey how you
doing you know it's not like some one of
those things I feel like I'm gonna go
over there it's gonna have like that
same vibe like Belfast had where I was
just like even if you didn't know some
[ __ ] went down the second you go there
you just like whoa some [ __ ] [ __ ]
went down here and you just immediately
act accordingly like I will not be
[ __ ] with anybody here all the best
stuff you and your family I will I'm
very very excited to see that part of
the world and we are putting it together
I would not bring it up if we weren't
putting it together all right
okay possible Eastern European tour
another one hey chief I was just
listening to your latest podcast July
2nd way you mentioned put it together in
Eastern European tour look at its look
at all the fans this is two people I
knew this tour would be successful
hopefully you'll have the balls to come
to Belgrade Serbia so I can see a
perform in person
well the second you tell me I need balls
to go where the [ __ ] you're from yeah I
could go [ __ ] you so I'm not going there
why don't what I need to have balls to
go there don't even talk about the
weather it's not Siberia hit Serbia you
know cuz I'm gonna go there and take a
[ __ ] farm tool to the side of my head
I don't need that [ __ ]
we got vampires there consider it as I'm
sure you'll have a blast here well I
know he scares the [ __ ]
hey there go go to the water park also I
don't know when you're planning to do
this tour but I recommend sometime
between September or November
hopefully you'll put some more specific
information out on this plan so no I was
thinking like January or February why is
that a bad time what happens in those
months anyway
love your Oh lows during January we
everybody stays inside then they let the
inmates run down the street it's like
running of bulls with murder anyways
love your shtick and wacky antics with
the occasion random hijinks rock on you
crazy bastard right just where you're
talking I think I'll be fine if I go
over there alright Obama's money hi bill
am I gonna get this [ __ ] kicked out of
me on this one
he signed a book deal you unread douche
I'll stop it stop it I don't want to
hear this [ __ ] I don't want to hear this
[ __ ] I don't want to hear this dude he's
gonna go around and he's good dude he
had 70 million dollars worth of [ __ ]
tour dates he also had that you
selectively on reading douchebag don't
tell me he [ __ ] who you he had a
[ __ ] 900 million dollar book deal
Obama 65 million book deal all right
wait a second wait a second and now I'm
gonna [ __ ] hit you back with my [ __ ]
Obama speaking dates money tour here we
go come on man big number big number big
member Michelle Obama tickets for 2018
Barack Obama four hundred thousand
dollars speaking fees reveal what whew
there we go
but bomber secures 800 grand for two
speaking it gate who you think he's
talking to huh he's go to a homeless
shelter the reason many of us have been
critical Barack Obama's outrageous four
thousand speaking fees
it robs us of a fantasy that sooner or
later the first black president was
going to use his considerable in or out
of office to help the economic ravages
of the poor who are disability black but
you know white person probably wrote
this I want to know who he's talking to
huh who the [ __ ] has 400 grand to throw
at this [ __ ] guy they're all fit I
don't know how to talk to you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so am I really supposed to sit here and
I'm supposed to think that these [ __ ]
guys like everybody with the blue tie I
just don't buy it
I don't [ __ ] buy it all right
okay 65 billion dollar book deal okay
after taxes sir after taxes and all the
[ __ ] that'll probably be about
thirty million bucks and I
guaran-fucking-tee you he is gonna be
worth when it's all said and done about
two hundred billion bucks okay and it's
not gonna be because he wrote a [ __ ]
book all right he's also gonna go out
and they do these speaking engagements
to all these corporations that they'll
pay them 400 [ __ ] grand and these are
the same people that got him into office
and he went in there and did what the
[ __ ] they wanted and this is just them
washing their bribe money
I mean honestly dude what changed when
he was in office that everybody is so
enamored with did we stop torturing
people down in Guantanamo did we [ __ ]
end the war over there are we finally
going like hey wait a minute
Isis doesn't have a plane or a boat why
are we acting like Germany got back
together no it's the same [ __ ] thing
it's the same goddamn sure it's the same
guy with a different colored time all
right I will [ __ ] read up on this hi
Bill love you shows you work it out
little the world
our most recent pocket you talked about
the house Obama just bought and wondered
where the money came from here's the a
piece that explains it it doesn't it
doesn't 65 million dollars you don't
turn around and you're only gonna get
thirty million dollars of that okay and
then you're gonna go out buy an 80
million dollar [ __ ] house you're
gonna pay at the 30 year note on that
paying interest on that because you just
basically got
thirty million dollars after taxes that
makes no [ __ ] sense all right and
also I would say I would actually be
willing to suggest that I am a [ __ ]
paranoid maniac that the information
that you're gonna they're not gonna tell
you can somebody explain to me how did
the Clintons become worth 100 's of
millions of dollars let me guess they
both wrote a book for 100 million
dollars each and they what they don't
pay taxes and that was it and then other
than that then like Jimmy Carter driving
around the world [ __ ] you know
building houses for the poor I never
claimed sir to be a hundred percent
[ __ ] read up on the [ __ ] I'm not even
two percent read up on it but neither
are you okay
this is not a piece that explains it
this is a piece that just shows this guy
cashing the [ __ ] 65 million is the
gross he's going to get about thirty
million bucks that's it because he's got
a kick in for this never-ending war -
all right so now he's got 30 million
bucks
he owes 82 million like what is the
[ __ ] payment on that a month now he's
gonna go around and he's gonna give all
these [ __ ] speeches okay and I
schools do not have the [ __ ] of the
you know I would say Ivy League schools
some of these bigger [ __ ] schools
maybe they have that but generally
speaking they go around and they talk to
these [ __ ] these corporations who got
him into [ __ ] office hey dude what
the [ __ ] me what do you do but but thing
you know every [ __ ] one of them I
don't know I think the whole [ __ ]
thing is weird it's all weird it's all
weird they he's a public servant and
blah blah blah blah and then the end of
the rainbow you were 200 [ __ ] million
dollars and you're living in the same
neighborhood as all those corporate
[ __ ] who pour [ __ ] into the [ __ ]
water supply like the fact that that
doesn't bother you on any goddamn level
and you're gonna just sit that way yet
you got 65 million for a book I mean
there you go I'm satisfied with that I
don't think the political system is
corrupt at all I don't think it's a bad
thing that
now corporations can dump unlimited
amount of funds into presidential
candidates I don't think that that
influences their their decisions on
foreign policy whatsoever I don't know
hey you know what sir agree to [ __ ]
disagree all right anyways I reread the
rest is it despite the fact that I don't
agree with you I will say that there are
[ __ ] on both sides however I however
believe that there is a lot to be said
about how one conducts themselves which
is why I side with Taylor II over Trump
yeah I love you people who like it's how
you conduct yourself as long as you
continue murdering innocent people it's
like it's not a problem but but they're
so eloquent when they give a speech do
you know why the president ages the way
they do it's because of the dead bodies
that's why it's not the economy it's not
the sketches on SNL and which is what
always cracks me up when you see like
people in Hollywood talking about how
they want to run for president you're
basically saying that you're so [ __ ]
in the head that you that you will that
you want to go to bed put your head on
the pillow going like did I do the right
thing we thought they were the enemy it
turned out to be a family there were
children there and you have to [ __ ]
go to bed and then the next day [ __ ]
smile and give some goddamn speech it is
the most [ __ ] that maybe maybe they
deserve the money I don't know maybe I'm
oversimplifying I am I always
oversimplify you know what sir I agree
with you you're probably right you know
what there you go that's how we got the
house he wrote a book hickory dickory
dock this chick was sucking my [ __ ] give
got stuck doing [ __ ] above Andrew Dice
Clay god bless you all right podcast
topic they built wondering if on an
upcoming podcast you can talk about how
your views may or may not have changed
on being a stay-at-home mom that you
were a parent yourself now they haven't
changed they haven't changed I think P
everybody exaggerates
how difficult their [ __ ] job is
alright listen being a single parent is
difficult I would say that would
probably be unbelievably [ __ ]
difficult however if you're [ __ ]
married you know what I mean
it's and you got one kid it's it's not
that hard the first three months yeah
you're hallucinating you know but you
get somebody to help you out a friend a
family member something to help you out
see state that the whole [ __ ] thing
where people trying to do it themselves
is goddamn and it's [ __ ] and saying
it's [ __ ] insane that's not that
people didn't do that back in the day
they used to say it takes a village to
raise a child back in the day you didn't
[ __ ] move to the other side of the
goddamn forest he just built a [ __ ]
log cabin right next to your parents
that was it they came over they helped
you out fought off a grizzly bear
okay no my views have not changed other
than I can't be honest with you when I
watch my kid I'm [ __ ] psyched I love
it I have a great goddamn time we play
games were screaming and yelling but
throwing balls all over the living room
and you know I don't know what the
problem is you know my buddy was
bitching about something talking about
he'd do something difficult they said
dude do you realize there's probably
some guy from Cuba right now that you
know made a boat out of a discarded desk
and his used in a [ __ ] sport coat is
a sail trying to get into this [ __ ]
country risking the fact that he's gonna
get caught sent back and god knows what
the [ __ ] happens to him and I don't know
what exactly is the problem with your
day it's it's what I would say ma'am is
it's about perspective which is what
that bit was about I'm not saying it's
not a challenging job I'm not saying
it's not an important job I just said
it's not the most difficult job on the
planet I would say that that people who
[ __ ] were trying when the lava was
coming down at their house and they
didn't have lava insurance
I would say it's a more trying day than
when your kid just would not stop crying
you know you want to hear kid not stop
crying went to that [ __ ] lavas at the
front door help should I tell my
boyfriend I'm a prostitute
okay no you and I know sometimes these
these emails get a little [ __ ] not
believable like what am I supposed to do
with this [ __ ] here this actually sir
help exclamation point should I tell my
boyfriend I'm a prostitute all right
what do I do here people do I ignore
this do I actually act like this is real
all right let's wait in - dear Billy
ball Baggins I'm a 25 year old semi
single lady living in the Netherlands
okay I've got good qualifications
master's degree and social well sounds
like outgoing yeah I'm not gonna argue
and try to treat other people with
kindness and respect god bless you
you're the prostitute with a heart of
gold Adam it you really have a master's
degree I'd really like to build a
special relationship in my life and I'm
currently dating a nice guy from Brazil
oh boy
but there's a catch for the past three
years I've been working in the sex
industry
I like my job make good money and always
practice safe sex oh boy oh boy get out
of that business sweetheart I don't want
to quit as it would mean busting my ass
is some corporate job working for the
man yikes you can't just be a stripper
you know no offense to strippers but
Jesus Christ yeah go out there shake
your ass a little bit you know hose
yourself off in the green room and just
walk away like it never happened for me
it's not a big deal to balance my job
and a loving relationship as I don't
find the work side of things emotionally
intimate at all however my boyfriend
seldom sees it the same way my
boyfriend's I am sure if I should be
honest with my new potential boyfriend
about my profession I'm unsure if I
normally I'm very honest and upfront my
boyfriend's about my job and normally it
kills the relationship oh I see I'm
starting to wonder if honesty is really
the best policy as the truth always
seems to add extra pressure and the
strain to the relationship and it hurts
me when I get attached to people and
they finish with me what do you think I
hope you and Nia had a nice time in
Paris and go [ __ ] yourself we had a
great time all right okay if this is
true sweetheart
yeah you know if you want to find a
loving relationship I think you need to
stop being a prostitute okay you know I
understand you know nobody understands
not want to ending up in a cubicle more
than me but I mean it's a [ __ ]
dangerous job you know it's a very
dangerous job there's a bunch of creeps
out there and I know you practice safe
sex but you know there's always problems
it's just you know yeah I don't know I
don't you know something I'm looking at
this as a you know that Puritan American
[ __ ] viewpoint I don't know if you're
free over-the-air the end I don't know
what the deal is but let's say I could
actually handle the fact these physical
aspects of the girl I was dating being a
prostitute which I couldn't let's just
say I could I would be so worried every
time she went out that someone was gonna
beat her up or killer I mean you're in
the sex industry
it's a [ __ ] horrible industry you
know I would you know I think you know
at least I would be worried about is how
I tell this [ __ ] guy I'm in the sex
industry I would be more worried - how
the [ __ ] do I get out of the sex
industry because what's gonna happen is
eventually you're gonna be an old
prostitute all right and I don't know I
used what you're investing your money in
Bitcoin or you know your own whorehouse
I have no idea what you're doing here
but like you know then all of a sudden
there's this big gap in your resume
where you weren't in a cubicle now you
trying to get a corporate job and you're
like you know what did you do from
2010 to 2021
oh I had sex for money
Oh oh okay well alright I don't think we
have any more questions I mean you know
assuming this is all true I would love
it if you got out of that industry just
get out of it you know enemy there's
easy money in my business too you know I
could go [ __ ] do it
Thank You whoring myself out you know
but you know what you always leave a
piece of yourself there back in that
room I don't know
you have a tremendous attitude I mean
you make it some fun I love it man you
know no get emotionally attached making
good [ __ ] money
you know this is when any woman group
would be like that's because she's so
numb from the zappity bed that boat you
know they start throwing their thoughts
into your [ __ ] head I don't know how
you're wired it might be [ __ ] true it
might not be true I don't have any I
don't have any fight this is this is way
above my pay grade I have no idea but uh
yeah you should [ __ ] tell somebody
that you're you know having sex for
money you know you probably want to know
that because it is dangerous you know
there's STDs of all that [ __ ] out there
yeah I guess I I would you know I would
tell him [ __ ] it you know I guess if you
can continue being a prostitute your
soul mates gonna be the person you don't
have to lie to if you can't accept me
for who I am you know all right I don't
know what I gotta do to get rid of this
[ __ ] we called it just came on slow oh I
might you know
doctor once telling me if it comes on
fast it goes away fast it comes on slow
goes away slow I guess that's what the
[ __ ] going on here but anyways that is
the podcast good luck to all four teams
left on the world cup good luck to that
prostitute and that Brazilian guy and
God bless the United States of America
and congratulations to Obama
for citing a 900 million dollar book
deal that's how he got that house that's
how he's gonna pay for it all you need
is 30 million bucks we're 82 [ __ ] if
I got a 60 million dollar [ __ ] book
deal and all I was gonna get was 30
million bucks out of it I was getting
for 2 grand a night I still wouldn't go
out buy an 82 million dollar house
I wouldn't [ __ ] do it an 82 million
dollar house is a [ __ ] white elephant
no offense to the Obamas all right I
mean when you turn around to sell that
thing I mean there's like point 1
percent of people that could actually
[ __ ] afford it you got to hope that
they're in the goddamn market I don't
know do you think of like drones around
it for old times sake oh that was a low
blow see bill this is why people think
you voted for trouble I don't like
making fun of Trump it's too [ __ ]
easy it is - in paying attention to him
it's too [ __ ] depressing you know oh
by the way I gotta tell you something
that don't be a Brad thing on [ __ ]
Instagram and I'm like that can't get
over that clip now that little [ __ ]
yelling at that bouncer the bounce that
goes can I get out of my face you little
[ __ ] or whatever and the kid is so
beside himself he's oh my god oh my god
do you have any idea what the [ __ ] my
dad does I cannot believe that a man
said that to another man do you have any
idea what the [ __ ] my dad does it's like
why is I'm not talking your dad there
son I'm talking to you what the [ __ ] do
you do other than buy little shirts but
what I love if you I've watched that
video so many times after that he
[ __ ] throws that little [ __ ] which is
so sad satisfying to watching to watch
when you listen to his friends they just
like oh dude you you are [ __ ] you are
you just [ __ ] up dude and the kid gets
up and like oh what is you know some
typos and don't what's going down and he
goes
you just [ __ ] up there they all walked
away right but they were so convinced
that this bouncer was [ __ ] into the
point I was sitting there like I was
feel like I'm satisfied like dude I want
to know what the [ __ ] your dad does do
you have an idea what the [ __ ] my dad
does I just all the way says oh my god
oh my god oh my god like he's like are
you seriously challenging me right now
you have any idea what the [ __ ] might
that what does he do
does he torture people for the CIA what
the [ __ ] does he do
oh my god
somebody's got to animate that that
bounce is sitting in the chair those
torturers they always have like the
[ __ ] tools out in front of you and
there's that little [ __ ] I told you man
I told you not to push me my little polo
shirt all right that's it
I apologize to Obama in all presidents
evidently they just do book deals it
just makes for two grand a night giving
speeches to you know banking :
conglomerates and that type of [ __ ] no
they don't they go down to a homeless
shelter so they'll scrape together
[ __ ] nickels that they they begged
for that day I have no [ __ ] idea and
you know what neither does the guy who I
loved how he looked up one [ __ ] thing
that's why I just I love doing a podcast
as I get I get that I am NOT that dumb
these people just as dumb as me you know
who would know Jimmy Dore I could have
jimmy dore in this I'm gonna have
[ __ ] Jimmy Dore in this podcast I'm
gonna save this I'm gonna save this
[ __ ] question I'm gonna read it to
Jimmy Dore alright oh my god oh my god
do you have any idea what the [ __ ] Jimmy
Dore reads
Jimmy Dore is gonna be my dad on this
question so I can win cuz I want to win
I don't wanna be right I just want to
win that's what it's about right
alright have a great week you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'll check in on you and Thursday